[موسيقى]
ما زلنا نقوم بالإعداد ولكن هل تعتقد
أننا سننتهي في غضون 30 دقيقة ، لا
يمكن أن يكون هذا على هذا النحو في وسط مدينة دبي ، كل شيء
على سطح السفينة لأنيشا أوبروي
هيا هيا بسرعة ، هيا
تستعد  حفل إطلاق منتج لديك 10
دقائق لإظهار الوقت ، أريد تنظيف كل شيء ،
نتوقع حوالي 30 شخصًا اليوم ، لذا
فإن أهم وسائل الإعلام وأصحاب النفوذ الذين
نعتقد أنهم يفهمون ما
نحاول إنشاؤه هنا
أنا متوتر قليلاً.  تأمّلت في
الصباح ، لذا يجب أن تسير الأمور على ما يرام
على الرغم من تأسيس شركتها الناشئة منذ أكثر من
عام ، هذا هو أول حدث عام لها على الإطلاق ،
نريد تعطيل مشهد الجمال
في الشرق الأوسط بشكل هادف
لأنه في يناير 2020 عندما
أبلغت الإمارات العربية المتحدة عن أول حالة لها  من
covet 19 كانت أنيشا تطلق
الجلد السري لشركتها للتجارة الإلكترونية
[موسيقى
] لم يعتقد الكثير من الناس
أنه الوقت
المناسب لإطلاقنا ، كان عليّ أن أكون فريقًا في
مكانه ، وكان عليّ أن أحصل على العلامات التجارية في مكانها الصحيح
وكان علي أن
أفعل كل شيء  بما أن على رائد الأعمال
القيام
به للحصول على كل البط على التوالي من
أجل الإطلاق ، فقد فعلنا ذلك طوال
الوباء ، وأعتقد أنه كان
خطرًا محسوبًا
[موسيقى]
بينما يواصل العالم
تحوله الذي تجني به شركات الإنترنت مثل أنيشا
أوبيروا  الفوائد
التي تبدو رائعة ورائعة
، من المهم حقًا بالنسبة لنا
تحديث المحتوى بحيث في كل مرة
يعود فيها العميل يكون قادرًا على
رؤية شيء جديد وطازج
تعلم خصوصيات وعموميات تشغيل
موقع التجارة الإلكترونية أثناء  العمل في واحدة
من أكثر الشركات نجاحًا في
العالم ،
هذا رائع ،
كنت جزءًا من الفريق المؤسس الذي
أطلق أزياء أمازون للتجميل في
الهند ، ثم أطلقناها في
أستراليا
لذلك تمكنت من بناء مخطط
الجلد السري كنتيجة  من بين كل
التدريبات التي تلقيتها
وكل ما تعلمته
، شهد الشرق الأوسط ازدهارًا في التجارة الإلكترونية
حيث
من المتوقع أن ترتفع مبيعات الوباء عبر الإنترنت
من حوالي 1  من 6 مليار في عام 2019 إلى أكثر
من 27 مليارًا في العام المقبل
[موسيقى]
لمواكبة الطلب ،
تميل أنيشا إلى تقنية ثورية
في صناعة الشحن والتوصيل
نحن في تحقيق الذكاء اليوم ، فهم
يتعاملون مع جميع الخدمات اللوجستية لدينا
وتجربة التسليم والتوصيل
كيف
حالك نتصافح ، كيف تسير الأمور بشكل
رائع
[موسيقى]
هذا المصنع هو أول
مركز آلي للوفاء في الشرق
الأوسط وشمال إفريقيا
[موسيقى]
هنا تعمل الروبوتات وقتًا إضافيًا لمعالجة
12000 طلب في اليوم ،
كما ترى الرجال  لقد اخترت بالفعل
طلباتك ،
كل شيء يتم الوفاء به
رائعًا ،
لقد أمضينا أسبوعًا جيدًا حقًا
لأن نعم نعم ، لقد قمت
بشحن المنتجات السرية حاليًا إلى
الهند وسلطنة عمان والكويت مع خطط
لإطلاقها في المملكة العربية السعودية هذا العام ، هذه
هي المرة الأولى التي أكون فيها  في الواقع ، عندما
نراقبهم وهم
يحزمون
الصندوق ، لكانت الحقيقة
مختلفة تمامًا لو
فتحنا متجرًا من الطوب وقذائف الهاون ، فلن يكون
لدينا عامل تمايز لن يكون
لدينا  قادرون على الفشل سريعًا في
الابتكار
والمحور ، أعتقد أننا اتخذنا
القرار الصحيح لكوننا متصلين بالإنترنت